Luke and Tom here at the outdoor Boys
YouTube channel and we're on an
uninhabited island in the middle of
Alaska and we're hiking through the
rainforest and up the mountains looking
for an abandoned World War II military
base we'll be camping and having an
amazing adventure
[Music]
there's purposes
well there goes our soul link to
civilization
we are on our own
welcome to rugged Island we're in
Resurrection Bay Alaska and me and Tom
are going to be exploring an abandoned
World War II Era military base during
World War II the Japanese invaded Parts
of Alaska and in order to defend the U.S
they put military bases all over the
coasts of Alaska and this is one of them
you can see the old dock pilings and
railroad ties that used to supply the
military base this place is super remote
and nobody comes here so I have no idea
how hard it's going to be to find that
base you ready to give this a try Tom
yes it's counting Dutch Hardware this
looks a little intense
ah
the old wooden beams that the railroad
tracks are on
follow the railroad tracks
hey Tom yeah why do you think they call
this rugged Island
we keep running into Devil's clubs look
at these bad boys
those are not fun to touch and they got
thorns on the underside of the leaves
man I could use a machete
that's a devil's club you just grabbed
are you okay
ouch
oh leash there's a view oh he did a bit
of climbing you can start to see how
high we gotta go though it's a beautiful
view we worked for it though didn't we
oh
you're out there now you can see why I'm
wearing rain slicks instead of something
a little bit more breathable you're
going through all this brush you get
absolutely soaked and the Thorns from
the devil's clubs go right through that
Gore-Tex it'll tear it all to pieces
oh look at this check out this is one of
the steel cable anchors they've wrapped
it around this tree
yay fly ground
there's a whole bunch of rails right
here
there's some pipe
there's some beams back in there
look at this
there's a trail is it the most beautiful
thing you've ever seen yes
yes this used to be a Jeep Trail see how
there's no big trees in the middle and
you can see where they kind of dynamite
it over here
each time we come to a fork in the road
we're putting sticks down to Mark which
way we're going and which way we're not
going
so I am really curious where this road
goes
oh
I'm okay
yeah that was a little bit of a booby
trap there
we're going down an awful lot
oh check it out Tom
someone or something's been here but you
grab the bear mace out of my bag just in
case
all right just in case I have no clue
whether there's any bears on this island
where'd you find something
here Tom go hard I want to film you
getting eaten I mean I want to film you
going inside
you can see where uh they drilled in
right there yeah I bet they use this to
store stuff
there you go I got my saw the saw does
really good as a machete
oh
take it out
molds turn the little sticks blue
everything just everything is covered in
Moss here
this is a temperate rainforest and when
we have really cold Winters this place
gets a ton of snow
yeah this doesn't look too bad sure you
want to fill up our water bottles
hold on wait wait wait wait
oh
look at this Dobby
literally right there there's the dock
and there's the rails we literally
bushwhacked our way all the way up that
hill and there was a road right there
what's got four thumbs and does things
the hard way
us okay kick off your backpack let's go
check the water out
stuff's edible
oh look at this yeah yeah it's a piece
of bull kelp
chewy
now the military base that was on this
island was called Fort bulkley and I've
found very little information about Fort
bulkley well little I did find said that
it would be on that Peak over there
across the bay but that's not the case
there's nothing over there oh look
there's a seal right over there Tom he's
right there he's kind of swimming
towards us yeah it does look like a
harbor seal
look at these
hey Tom
ha
ha there's like some sort of clear Jello
inside
but the big bumpy ones are good for
squirting
oh like
he could you can see it
alrighty
should we go try this path
we're up in the clouds now oh look and
this is the other side of the island
but it is so steep over on this part oh
my goodness look at this
there's Stiller sea lions down there
yeah that is insane I think I could
throw a rock from the top of this island
all the way into the ocean
yeah there's a reason why they call it
rugged Island
we went up the nice part
I'm not really sure where the fort is on
this island but the ocean's there the
ocean's there and we run out of Island
that way
so it must be that way
look at these salmonberry bushes come
back here in a month or two and this
place would be crawling with big juicy
salmon berries
I'm not sure how long it's been since
people were on this Trail but I've seen
no Footprints no broken branches no
signs of Life luckily it's pretty hard
to get lost I can see the boundaries of
the old road pretty clearly oh look at
this Tom I see a structure yeah there's
a concrete bunker right over there every
time you got your flashlight
all right all right
okay
oh yeah okay
this is just like a little office or a
place in store ammo or something
like a little candy bar you want it sure
I've got one of these melon kitkats
well you want to go see if we can find
more yeah yeah all right let's keep
going
there's some pipes that come up into the
woods up there it's got to be something
up there
so you know these are Wood Pipes from
the World War II era they make them like
you do a wood barrel and then they wrap
them in metal wire
well it looks real flat doesn't it
it's the foundation
I've seen a number of pipes that go up
the hill so there's some man-made
structures up there I'm just not quite
sure where it is
oh
little concrete box of some type here
yeah there's some railroad ties
some more random military ruins in the
woods oh look at this huh
look at this
there's a rope up here Tom here I'll
drop my bag
yeah it is check it out
there's a bunker right here
that was a big jump top
you know is it this is a chimney look at
this oh military boots
look at that they're steel toed
oh check it out this is the Coast Guard
Beacon
oh there's a ladder yeah I'll go first
yeah it is Sir
check this out
no way
oh
it's beautiful isn't that pretty
oh dang there's like what a fabulous
spot for an observation post
concrete for that is gone oh
that's just hanging out over the cliff
s
I wonder what other stuff
higher up though it's a third kin
structure
oh
look at this
this is an old military car
yeah this is this is the piece to a
military bed oh it's so hard to see
anything in these Woods we could be
walking past dozens of these buildings
and not even know it
Trail was
Pottery right there
oh you know what this is this is a wash
tub
what is this
yeah it's a bowl I think that's where
they did their dishes yeah it could have
been could have been where they did
their dishes look at that
yeah there's a whole bite building
you can see almost all of these trees
have grown since the base was here
we found some cool stuff Tom but we
haven't found the artillery placement
whole point of these military bases was
to put an artillery piece on top of
these islands and and shoot enemy ships
they were trying to enter the bay
check it out there's all these
look at all these wires well they moved
them out so there must be something up
there if we follow the wires
off to the roof
there's a lot of wood here rotten wood I
think we're standing on the collapsed
roof of a wooden structure and that
concrete is the foundation and this
right here this is the roof that's left
of the roof
[Music]
careful this is deep
deep oh
yes
look at this Tom
this is a insulator for power lines okay
so there's power cables they're going
further up the hill there's more up
there
a little m m break
dad tax
look at this Tom
that's a tread do like a bulldozer or a
tank right there
look there's a big open flat spot there
isn't a single flat spot on this island
that isn't man-made
oh look at that
this is it I think we found it
[Music]
here grab my flashlight oh look at this
Tom
that is pretty cool is it look at this
it's like the latches to the door
Thomas you ready to go explore
let's go inside see a uscd
1943. so that's two years before the end
of World War II all right
you got your light
all right let's go inside
watch out oh there's booby traps here
yeah here's another
[Music]
two dead boxes down here yeah I wonder
if it just fell down there and got
trapped
okay
oh here's the big room yes another door
in here dang this place is Big
there's a basement
oh look at that oh there's stairs
this place is getting cool
I think these are sheets of like
asbestos it's a kind of a fireproof
insulation but it's a toxic gives you
cancer
[Music]
it's like a big engine room and there's
tons of stuff in there
look at this this is like a giant
drafting table or something this isn't
good
that looks structural right there
was that pretty cool yes was that worth
the hike
yeah yeah you know what that is Tommy
that looks like a cesspit
as
Tom I found it come here
yeah see how it's round Tom that's where
the big turn
yeah they put the gun in the middle and
then they can turn they can spin it
around any direction and they could
blast any enemy ship trying to come into
Resurrection Bay
so right now we're climbing on top of
the big bunker
we're gonna see what there is to see up
here can't believe all these trees are
growing on top of that concrete bunker
there's something up here
look at this
whoa
look at this Tom it's a machine gun
bunker got the bulletproof plates on
Rails and you can slide them over the
entrances to protect you his pillbox is
on the roof of that complex we explored
yes it looks like it's in good shape
it's solid wood
it's got the wooden shutters so that you
can close it when it's cold
I wish this was like
look at this holy Macker look at look at
the size of this door
it's just a big room but this must be
where they stored the artillery shells
yeah because you wouldn't want to store
these where all the people were because
if it blows up you don't want it to wipe
out the whole base
seems like there's building and bunkers
all over the place so I'm sure we've
missed a few but we've searched all the
trail and road that we can Tommy's
fingers are getting cold so I think it's
time to make camp
thank you
well this was definitely the driest and
cleanest of all the bunkers I think it
is a good place to camp
it is so nice not to be rained on
let's get this stuff out of the way
all right
oh my bag is a bit wet
my backpack is supposed to be waterproof
but it's getting pretty old and has some
holes in it and I got a lot of water in
my bag I think luckily the stuff sack
for my sleeping bag stopped most the
water
Pell is a little wet on one side but not
bad
lay down
hey Tom does that feel better yeah
okay I'm gonna get you some hot
chocolate too okay all right
all right both of us out huh more fun
Tommy's having hot chocolate I'm gonna
have some hot Tang
for those of you that were alive in the
80s you might remember that powdered
drink mix Tang well it's still alive and
well here in Alaska and we like to drink
it hot
[Music]
put some boiling
wattle here make you feel that you put
that in your bag does that feel good
yep
there's a whole
got some bread flour and yeast
just seal that up Let it ferment
all right Tom let's see about dinner
here you want creamy pasta and chicken
beef stew
there we go nice little bit of fry bread
well typically I like to eat this with
some honey or butter or Jam but I forgot
to bring all that so we're gonna put a
little powdered Tang on it and see what
happens
it's a little weird with the Tang on it
but it's not bad you like it
warm Bread's hard to beat isn't it
[Music]
good morning Tom
so what do you think of your first night
sleeping in a World War II bunker hey it
was awesome all right it's time to get
up
I think it's time to get up and start
packing
oh look at this I actually got a little
bit of a view
nice
yes cool
right on that green now we just gotta
wait for the water taxi to come pick us
up it's nice to get out of that brush I
can finally take my rain gear off and
start to dry out a little bit even
though it's not raining that vegetation
is so wet that walking through it gets
you soaked can't see it but we can hear
a boat engine ah there's a boat
ready go
how's your day been
okay
right there that's the top of the
mountain we were on
top you got it is that fun time yeah
you're hungry yes all right let's go get
a burger or something all right you want
it
gross some warm food feels good doesn't
it yeah
yeah well hopefully you guys enjoyed
watching this little adventure of ours
if you want to see more videos from the
outdoor Boys YouTube channel don't
forget to click subscribe now nailed it
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every Saturday morning and hit
that Bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching
[Music]